hello and welcome to part 13 of our
fundamental investing with the use of
Python programming tutorial where we
left off we were getting this data from
quando populating these arrays and
that's pretty much where we left off
we're always printing out the data just
so we can see it with our eyeballs so
now the next thing we want to do is
convert these arrays to numpy arrays and
then with that conversion to a numpy
array we can start to plot them within
matplotlib so do all that first we're
gonna have to get some more imports here
so we want import matplotlib and then we
also want to do import matt flaw live
dot type lot as PLT just to keep it
short for us we're going to also import
matplotlib dot ticker as M ticker and
well we probably won't be using this but
we'll just throw it in there just in
case M ticker will allow us to make an
edit that you'd like to see probably in
a little bit here but we'll just leave
it for now and then the other thing we
want to do is import Matt plot and that
plot lib dot m dot dates as M dates and
what that's gonna allow us to do is is
read dates so oh we also need a number
so import numpy as NP now if you are
just joining us and you haven't done any
of these things if you don't have
matplotlib or numpy i highly suggest you
either watch i'm there's a matplotlib
tutorial series and then also if you
watch the python charting tutorial
series we go through the installation of
matplotlib and numpy and then also if
you have a 64-bit version of python you
can also get numpy from i forget what
the name of the website is but i even
have a video on that as well for getting
64-bit imports for things that don't
have 64-bit install installers
so anyway that's that continuing right
along if you need links to any of those
videos just comment below if you can't
find them I'll link you to those videos
if anybody needs them
so the now that we have this stuff what
we want to do is begin our conversion of
these regular boring arrays into numpy
arrays so once we populated those rays
we'll come down here and my tab is not
working apparently oh yay anyway um okay
so the first one will do is let's say we
want to do the net income array so let's
call this income date comma income
equals then we're going to use some num
pies load text functionality you can
either load literally a text document
here you can also load a raise list and
actually in Python even though you know
we put these little brackets around it
it's really a list but so I call them a
raise and luckily nobody's come in here
with their nose up in the air and said
hey there's no such thing as a raise but
anyway continuing on and so what we want
to load is this list or array net income
R so that's the thing that we're gonna
load in and then you have to tell it
what the delimiter is and in our case it
is just a comma and then unpack equals
it's just a straight up true you
capitalize it though then what we want
to do is is use M dates so it can read
our date format and convert that into
something that can be charted so to do
that you do converters and any
parameters of the converter sorry it's
converters equal and then do these
little curly braces right and within
there
the what you need to say is what element
are we converting it's going to be the 0
with elements it's the first part of the
list then what do we want to do with
that we want to use M dates dot
rip day to numb and no I didn't typo its
STRP
dat e then number two and then n um and
it's gonna convert it to a number but
it's not a UNIX timestamp so don't think
you could just throw a UNIX timestamp in
there it's like I don't even know I'm
not positive of how they're generating
that number but anyway I forget one time
I found out how it goes like what order
it goes I want to say like a day is a
like a 1 and so on but anyway forget so
in here you specify the parameters of
that date format and so a % uppercase Y
means a full year so like 2013 as
opposed to a lowercase Y would mean like
if the date just had like 13
so anyway 2013 and then our date format
has a - and then month and then % d for
day if you're curious I do have it's the
same as if you were converting a UNIX
timestamp to a date stamp or a date
stamp to a UNIX timestamp I do have
tutorials on that if anyone's curious
about all the variations of this like
sometimes you might get a date stamp
that literally writes out the month or
you might get a date stamp that
literally writes out maybe the day of
the week or something like that right
and so you want to know how to handle
that stuff I do have a tutorial on all
of that but for now this is what we'll
need to read this quand elle data so
that's the end of it and let's let me
just confirm here that that was closes
that yes ok so that closes it off so now
we've created a numpy array from this
data so now now we can actually plot
this data now in the interest of in like
one video I guess it'll probably not the
next video but probably the video after
that we're going to incorporate this
with our other charting applica
so in the interest of that we're not
going to you'll see but the x-axis will
be in this number format that is like
the numpy or matplotlib dates numbers
and don't cry it's okay we'll fix that
in like a whole nother video but just
just know it's coming soon and we could
fix it really quickly but I really just
there's no point to do it because we're
gonna push it into this other
application that we've got going on - so
anyway it just heads up for that
so for matplotlib we have to define the
figure so figure eagles plot figure
event and this this will change but you
could put some parameters in here but
for now we'll leave that blank now we're
gonna say ax one can only have one axes
equals plot dot subplot to grid and
we're going to use this functionality
because that's what our application uses
and then here you just put whatever you
want yeah the one that we're gonna move
to is currently six by four and so
that's the size of the whole grid and
the next parameter is where we start in
that grid and it starts you know top
left so we start at zero zero then you
specify row span we're just going to
take up the whole thing with this crap
so it's gonna say row span 6 and then
column span for call span equals four
and so we'll take up the whole thing but
eventually we'll be able to like mold
and put some other charts on here so so
that's that now a X 1 dot fly what do we
want to plot this easy part income date
and then income and again it's not going
to be in pretty date format yet but we
will get there
but I just want to graph this and show
it to you guys so we should be good to
go so run it and hopefully so printed
out all of our stuff so that's the date
format for anybody that was couldn't
remember I guess and you should have got
a graph here that popped up for you as
long as you had numpy and matplotlib
installed and so here's what I was
talking about the date format it's very
ugly but well like I said well we will
eventually fix that I have
fear but anyway so this is the net
income for what are we doing even I
think Yahoo is what we've been running
yeah so anyway Yahoo on you know long
scale looks like their income has been
doing pretty good so that's the basics
of throwing up a graph and a matplotlib
based on the data that we're reading
from cuando now the next video what
we're gonna do is do the other the other
arrays add them up here so just in case
all you cared about was was this stuff
we can do that and I'll show you guys
how and then probably in the subsequent
video after that we're gonna plug this
into our other charting application for
some pretty supreme epicness then after
that then we'll connect it with the head
of the program being our screener and
then when it finds a stock it'll spit
out all this data it'll spit out the
chart the price the RSI the MACD and
then also the net income revenue and
return on capital historically so pretty
cool stuff coming up pretty fast
hopefully you guys are enjoying as
always thanks for watching